well you do act like a 12 year old
and Johnny Cage clearly has the Home
Advantage yeah that's true
although I mean you could make the case
that he's gonna be more tentative while
fighting because he doesn't want to
break everything oh yeah he definitely
would not want anything right it's a
really nice looking art in that film and
an indoor pool in the front room there's
a giant picture of himself in there as
well which I absolutely love
of me
oh that's a perfect example
he risked it to get that meter up and
totally lost because of it but one of
those little meta things there is maybe
he felt it was a losing round anyway it
was worth it to have it for the next
round fun fact during during development
the Flamingo back there like there were
multiple times where if you did like a
big hit or something it would just go
flying out of the pool
good punish on that
Factory row
the breakers look so cool in this
I love it because again with cameos
they're all different yes
oh good punish oh and swag wow I'm using
the teleport in a combo very very cool
oh and that that overhead gets me all
the time
he's out of here yeah
I love the cameras on the throws too
they're very very cool
man you canceled out of it yep you just
wanted to check it out
if you need me I'm here if you need me
he's been sitting on hype he has not
activated the whole time oh excellent
use of peanuts Cameo there too you need
to punish and here we go
very smart from scorpion he was ready
for it the hype mode is active
here we go oh my god oh how many times
he's gonna hit the person in the crotch
wow a 50 combo with hype
you wait till the possibly the last
round yeah excellent with punishment
scorpion
I don't care about how rounds work
I love this trial
just sitting there back there taking a
frame of it
oh that Johnny Cage oh he almost taught
him right there
he would have gotten the uppercut
brutality if that was the case scorpion
wants nothing to do with this
oh
so do you want to explain that fatal
blow the attack into it is actually a
Parry that he can hold
likes here
and we're gonna save that for next time
for another time another time okay
nice well big thanks to QA that was an
awesome fight yes that was fantastic
when they first sent it to me I was like
oh that's exactly what I wanted just
amazing so